morning no as a student
Borderlands the pre-sequel is about
handsome Jack's rise to power it's a
sequel to borderlands one and a prequel
to borderlands 2 it's an all new full
standalone experience you're on handsome
Jack's team you're going to follow him
and his rise to power when we finished
Borderlands 2 and as we dove into the
dlc for it we really had so much more we
wanted to bring to the board lines
universe that's why it was so exciting
to discover that the team down in 2k
Australia was available we talked to
their design as a designer talk to our
designers the design team is pretty much
one design team and that pretty that
cater wherever to every discipline
whether that be narrative whether that
be design programming ah it's all fairly
much intertwined now everything that
they bring to the table everything the
2k Australia events and adds to
borderlands is a surprise i also am
consuming all this stuff like a fan for
the first time and it's been a real
treat we've got four new characters
classes for Duane's for sequels first
one being an issue that the wall bring
up we have a finger the gladiator we
also have will help now Wilhelm woods
from Borderlands 2 as well I'm one of
the ones that we're really excited about
he's bringing claptrap as a playable
character for the first time one of the
coolest things about Borderlands the
pre-sequel is because it's built start
as a starting point from the borderlands
2 technology has all of the advantages
and all the features and all the
capabilities of that game and with the
new environments bringing low gravity
and no atmosphere there's a tremendous
opportunity for new gameplay that the 2k
Australia guys have just blown me away
with we've invented things like a low
oxygen because doesn't have atmosphere
so what can you do with some mechanics
with Pat with oxygen so we haven't just
made it a resource we've made into a
strategy ya allah when I first realized
that I could use the oxygen tanks as a
jetpack and have longer jumps have
double jumps I can hover I can fly I
mean it just added a whole new loop and
then when I'm up there they added this
new feature I call it a ground pound I
don't even know if it has an official
name but basically when you're when
you're flying when you're hovering
when you're midair you hit the Crouch
button BAM you just smash straight to
the ground leave an impact stun
everybody it's so much fun Borderlands
the pre-sequel is going to come later in
2014 it's going to come to the xbox 360
the playstation 3 and Windows PC it's a
great time to jump in and check out what
all the fuss is about
you